thank you
in the early Universe go back to the big
bang and you have this cauldron of
matter and energy well we don't have
stars yet we don't have galaxies yet
this organizing principle of stars as
they gather into cities no it's just
matter and energy and it takes a while
for the expanding Universe to cool so
that matter can coalesce to make stars
and ultimately galaxies so there's a
period of time
after light was sent free in the
universe because before then it was
constantly interacting with matter and
the universe was just a fog light gets
set free once we've expanded enough this
happened around 400 000 years after the
big bang now light is set free but okay
we don't have any objects that generate
light okay so in this period between
forty thousand years and the first Stars
we call that the Dark Ages there was
nothing there to radiate yes there was
left over light from The Big Bang but no
objects talking to us so we calculate we
put on a best understanding of the
universe for Gravity quantum physics and
nuclear fusion physics and all of this
we put on our best thinking caps and say
it'll take about this long one or two
billion years just to get the stars
going and then you need enough stars in
a place to gather and make a Galaxy and
a Galaxy will have enough light for you
to see from a great distance it'd be
very hard to see individual Stars okay
that's our model of the early universe
[Music]
now we say we don't understand how
galaxies are born let's make a telescope
to help us so we Speck the Next
Generation Space Telescope after Hubble
to be exquisitely tuned to show us
galaxies being born and we expect it to
show us galaxies at the end of the Dark
Ages at the birth of objects in the
universe so we design and build this
telescope the James Webb Space Telescope
now what's different about it because
we'd expect galaxies that are just born
to be giving off intense amounts of high
energy light ultraviolet light
especially because certain classes of
brand new stars give off copious amounts
of this kind of Light how do we see
those galaxies today well if that was
that long ago and the universe has
expanded that ultraviolet light is no
longer ultraviolet light no over the
expansion of the universe those
wavelengths have been stretched
13.8 billion years later today
ultraviolet light emitted at the early
Universe has been stretched to become
infrared light oh my gosh okay well we
knew this would happen but it's kind of
it's amazing that we can
fool the universe and to say you're not
we know you gave off ultraviolet when
you're born and we're going to look for
you in the infrared you're not going to
get by us so we make the James Webb
spell Space Telescope exquisitely tuned
to see infrared emission that started
out as ultraviolet in the early Universe
bada bing we turn on the telescope oh by
the way infrared is also good for
looking inside gas clouds that are
sitting in front of our nose to see the
birth of stars otherwise cloaked in the
gas clouds from which they're born cloth
you can
because the visible light scatters and
you can't see it it's hidden if you're
using visible light but if you use
infrared light that infrared comes from
the stars and Pops right out of those
gas clouds and you see where all the
stars are as well as the newborn planets
in orbit around this so the James Webb
Space Telescope is good for Stuff nearby
just as it's good for Stuff long ago
alright so now let's tune the telescope
in to galaxies being born
and oh my gosh who ordered this we're
finding
galaxies
in the Dark Ages
we have no idea what
my idea and I'm told the lead researcher
was so shocked by this he spit out his
coffee when he realized what kind of
data he had on his hands so I can give a
list what's the list either we don't
understand how galaxies are formed of
course we don't fully understand it
that's why we built the telescope but
all of our understanding about matter
and energy that tells us that this
should be a dark ages something had to
change we got to go back and adjust that
somehow in ways we don't know or
understand yet or some
kind of object
had no trouble forming in the Dark Ages
or us placing it in the Dark Ages is
somehow flawed we're basing this on just
pictures of these galaxies and what
their properties are via pictures what
we are waiting for now is we want to get
a spectrum of those galaxies of those
objects let me not even call them
galaxies because it could be something
else
you can tell us what chemical elements
are there a rainbow is a spectrum of the
sun right white light comes through goes
through a raindrop out comes its
component colors if you looked even more
carefully at it those colors reveal the
chemistry of what's going on in the Sun
the chemical elements that are there you
can also find out other things like how
fast does the Sun rotate all kinds of
things you can find out when you get the
Spectrum so if we get the spectrum of
these objects we'll know what they're
made of we will even be able to better
place them in distance maybe there's
something contaminating our estimate of
its distance and maybe they're really on
the edge of the Dark Ages but somehow
they're masquerading as though they're a
little farther away deep within the Dark
Age who knows or as some people love to
speculate when they encounter something
they don't understand they're aliens
foreign
if that's your first thought okay I'm
not gonna stop you but generally we
leave that for the last possible guess
that we would place on something that we
don't understand and by the way just to
be fair to us we built this telescope
for this purpose
help us understand the birth of galaxies
when you build a new telescope with
access to times and places and regimes
in the universe open a new window on
Cosmic phenomenon yes it'll help you
understand things you already had some
idea about but you know what else it
always does makes discoveries you had no
way to even anticipate and that is the
glory of science on the frontier so if
you see a newspaper article oh
scientists have to go back and adjust
their cherish theories and go back to
the drawing board
we're always at the drawing board
because that's the fundamental feature
of what it is
to make discoveries in this world to
stand with one foot inside the circle
and put a foot outside where we have yet
to peer because as the area of our
knowledge grows so too does the
perimeter of our ignorance
in your life you must learn to love the
questions themselves and celebrate the
unknown rather than fear it and that's
what's up with that
[Music]